- [Narrator] A university
offers a certain course
that students can take in-person
or in an online setting.
Teachers of the course were curious
if there was a difference
in the passing rate
between the two settings.
Data from a recent semester showed
that 80% of students passed
the in-person setting
and 75% of students
passed the online setting.
They were willing to treat these
as representative samples of all students
who may take each setting of the course.
The teachers used those results to make
a 95% confidence interval to estimate
the difference between
the proportion of students
who pass in each setting of the course.
So this is a 95% confidence interval
for the difference between the proportion
who passed the in-person course
and the online course.
The resulting interval was approximately,
it went from negative 0.04 to 0.14.
Just to make sure we understand
what this is saying, this is saying 95%
of the time that you go through this,
because we're talking about
a 95% confidence interval,
95% of the time you take these samples
and then you construct
a confidence interval
for the difference in proportions,
that it will actually
contain the true proportion.
They want to use this interval to test
their null hypothesis
that the true proportions
are the same versus their
alternative hypothesis
that the true proportions are different.
Assume that all conditions for inference
have been met.
Based on the interval, what do we know
about the corresponding P-value
and conclusion to their test?
So pause this video and try to figure out
on your own.
All right, so what's interesting here
is we're going to use
a confidence interval
to think about a hypothesis test.
Remember, in a hypothesis test
we assume that our null
hypothesis is true.
We'll assume this.
There's another way we could write it.
We could write it like this,
that the difference between
the in-person and the
online, true proportions,
is equal to zero.
These are equivalent statements.
In a hypothesis test, we will assume
that this is true.
Then in a traditional hypothesis test,
we set some significance level.
So let's say we set that
significance level at 5%
and that is a very typical
significance level.
And if the results we
get, if the probability
of getting the results that we do get
for the difference in
the sample proportions
is less than 5%, we say
hey that's pretty unlikely
we're gonna reject the null hypothesis
which will suggest the alternative.
But here we have something interesting.
We have a confidence interval.
It turns out that if the
sum of your confidence level
and your significance
level is equal to 100%
and you're doing a
two-sided hypothesis test,
so you're thinking about well,
our alternative hypothesis isn't just that
the in-person is greater than the online,
or that it's less than the online,
it's that they are different.
We have a two-sided hypothesis test.
In these situations you can
actually make some inferences
about your P value from
your confidence interval.
Think about it this way, we are assuming
our null hypothesis is true when
we do this hypothesis test.
And so when we construct
a 95% confidence interval,
we would expect that 95%
of confidence intervals
would overlap with zero.
Where did I get zero from?
Remember, this is a confidence interval
for the difference in proportions.
Our null hypothesis is
that the true difference
in proportions is zero.
So 95% of the time that we do this,
if we assume that the
null hypothesis is true,
we will overlap with zero.
Or another way you can think about it.
5% of confidence intervals
would not overlap with zero.
So if you are in a situation where
you go through this process, you try
to construct a 95% confidence interval
and you don't overlap with
your assumed difference
of the true proportions
from your null hypothesis,
well in this situation your P value
is going to be less than
your 5% significance level.
In this situation you would
reject your null hypothesis.
In this first situation your P value
is going to be greater than
or equal to your alpha level
and you would fail to reject.
So what's the situation here?
Well our interval actually does include
the assumed difference in true proportions
from the null hypothesis.
So that means assuming the null hypothesis
we are in this first scenario.
This is one of the 95%
of confidence intervals
where we actually did overlap with
the true parameter that
we are trying to estimate.
In that situation our P value is going
to be greater than or equal to our alpha,
which in this case is 5%.
So we fail to reject the null hypothesis.
So there isn't evidence to suggest
that there is a true difference
in passing grades between the in-person
and the online exam.